[Musique]
8h06 le matin dans une résidence privée
pour aînés de charlesbourg en banlieue
de québec une caméra cachée capte
l'image d'une femme de ménage qui
s'empare de quelque chose dans la
chambre d'une résidente
mammare on lui apporte une touche au col
c'est quelque chose que j'adore et là
son discours était je me fais voler du
chocolat 12h19
le même jour la femme de ménage récidive
l'on s'est dit ben ma mère souffre un
peu d'alzheimer pata que bon elle en
offre aux hôtels l oubli look elle en a
faim
12h27 une lendemain puis on observait
aussi en même temps la différence dans
son comportement alors que l'anxiété
l'insécurité l'eau ça commence un petit
peu là nous mettre la puce à l'oreille
10h57 10h58
10h59 11h13
c'est ce qu'on voit reste que tous les
jours en juillet 2014 quand marie claude
matheu cache une caméra dans la chambre
de sa mère elle pense qu'elle va
découvrir qui subtilise son chocolat
mais elle découvre bien pire
[Musique]
c'était vraiment intéressant comme
endroit éclairé elle avait un balcon
belles portes patio
c'est vraiment règles pendant six mois
marie-claude matt considère que la
voisine hier de charlesbourg et la
résidence idéal pour sa mère mais peu à
peu les allégations de vol et
l'insécurité de sa mère mine sa
confiance
la parle j'ai dit je vais faire un tfc
le j'ai apporté le 8 mois de grosses
boîtes de chocolat avec plus de grosses
palette de chocolat et moi je retourne
le lendemain comme on fera le lundi par
la première chose que je vérifie c'est
son chocolat il ne reste que deux boîtes
seulement sur sur les 8 et il ne restera
aucune période de chocolat
marie-claude mats ek il y à des caméras
de surveillance dans les corridors de la
résidence elle demande aux propriétaires
de faire enquête
monsieur le même état doute que chokolo
mais le pauvre vue à partir de ces
caméras il m'a pas vu entrer avec les
chocolats ma mère souffre de la marque
saab il faut faire attention c'est des
gens qui font de la démence
parfois ils peuvent inventer il faut
être on n'avait pas en santé pour les
coûts du support
madame matt décide de dissimuler une
caméra dans la chambre de sa mère
[Musique]
dans une autre région du québec nathalie
richard aussi a vécu une expérience
difficile avec sa mère qui elle était
hébergée dans un ch et celle des publics
hier commence à voir des voix des
bouteilles de parfum qui disparaissaient
des 10 ou pas des gros montants
les petits-enfants tranquillement des
vêtements et sous vêtements ça disparaît
c'est souvent des fois c'est assez lippi
la phase attend le fauteuil roulant
jamais la vie s'en sort-elle urines il
s'en occupe et pau
madame richard rédige une liste de ses
doléances et la remets à la chef de
l'unité où sa mère est hébergée n'ont
jamais rien fait pour eux on voit les
faire des recommandations
sap aurait cinq ans ça continue et le 19
novembre 2013
c'en est trop pour les richards l'etec
prometteuse ça faisait l'infection et
ronald grave au sein 40 degrés de fièvre
la bouche ouverte depuis le temps qu'on
arrive il a renié disposait c'est mon
frère it arrive avant moi c'est lui qui
fait appeler le neuf ans ça faisait déjà
trois fois l'automne qu'on la rentrée à
l'hôpital new mind l'eis objecte t on un
protocole à suis engagé à ce que chez
moi à serait déjà parti
le lien de confiance est rompu moi je me
suis pas caché pour installer une caméra
ils ont été avisés l'ont vu le cam héros
la caméra installée par sylvain richard
et bien en évidence via internet
elle transmet les images de ce qui se
passe dans la chambre en direct sur son
téléphone
qu'est ce que ça lui apporter de savoir
qu'à tout moment vous étiez capable de
l'avoir beaucoup de sécurité personnelle
beaucoup de de savoir qui est porteuse
aux états comptant est à contente
d'avoir une voix telle au jeu subtil les
richards utilise aussi la caméra de
surveillance pour communiquer avec leur
mère qui à cause de son handicap ne peut
pas toujours répondre au téléphone
comme je parle sur le répondeur du
téléphone de la commune de minutes pour
lui parler
facing à me rassurer tout est beau bien
parler mon java sont fait entendre des
taux de plus en plus de familles
inquiètes ont recours à des caméras de
surveillance après l'ena nikam destiné à
surveiller les gardiennes d'enfants
on assiste à l'essor du marché des
grains nikam pour surveiller grand maman
il y a les modèles qu'on met bien en
évidence et les autres qui se cachent
dans des sacs des prises de courant des
thermostats des détecteurs de fumée on
voit cette industrie se développe est là
parce que les le public les personnes
âgées des associations d'aînés ont perdu
confiance dans les établissements
louis plamondon et président de la qdr
l'association québécoise de défense des
droits des retraités
récemment il a acheté deux caméras
cachées qu'ils prêtent aux familles
insatisfaite des lieux d'hébergement de
leurs vieux parents
dionne forte inquiétude que des
situations problématiques support soit
des vols soit de la brusquerie de la
bousculade et privations d'isolement et
yacine pas de réponses à leurs questions
donc ils viennent ici chercher des
moyens pour établir les preuves de
mauvais traitements
des preuves c'est ce que marie-claude
match cherchait en deux semaines elle a
cumulé une soixantaine de vidéos on voit
certaines employées faire du bon travail
mais dans une trentaine de vidéos on
voit trois employés se servir
allègrement dans les chocolats de madame
toujours en l'absence de celles ci ou
lorsqu'elles d'or
au moins ma mère qui est malheureuse
puis on voit que à doit se préoccuper de
cacher c'est son chocolat au lieu de
prendre soin d'elle à plusieurs reprises
agrippée à son déambulateur la mère de
marie claude matt déploie beaucoup
d'efforts pour mettre son chocolat à
l'abri mais ça ne donne rien les
préposés ne se gêne pas même quand le
chocolat est au fond des tiroirs
[Musique]
en regardant la vidéo il est difficile
de croire que la mère de madame matt est
d'accord pour partager ces gâteries
il n'y a pas que la disparition du
chocolat qui témoigne d'un manque de
professionnalisme
on voit là la préposée demande à ma mère
si elle veut du seven up donc mamadou
oury fait qu'on voit la personne
chercheurs venant à bout ce n'est pas ma
mère en place un bain à 100 points de
petites gorgées remet la bouteille
ces gens lyon pas de conscience pas de
conscience c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire madame et à la toilette il pendant
que cette préposée dit chercher ses sous
vêtements
elle en profite pour fouiller dans les
tiroirs fouillés dans le porte monnaie
un chocolat au ch et celle d où la mère
de nathalie et sylvain richard était
hébergé la caméra était bien visible et
n'avait pas pour objectif premier de
prendre les employés en défaut
pourtant elle a provoqué une crise
majeure avec le personnel commence à
être
bike froid par les pumas mans il a plein
sur d'autres beaux ainsi garder soit
d'abord en plus de communication que les
résidents puissent communication et de
la famille pitt sourire il me faisait
sortie de la chanson corps humain il
rentra coûte trop pourquoi 3,3 passes
qui en avait un qui s est caché caméra
bien avait dit qu'ils travaillaient
m'écouter s'ils se comportent
correctement c'est quoi le problème
il ya beaucoup d'entreprises privées qui
est pour des raisons juste n'est que les
banques dans le maniement de l'argent
qui sort des guichets les employés sont
filmés en permanence d'accord en
permanence il était pour bris mais c'est
à 5,12 des fautes troubles des pauvres
de cabaret fly100 vos noms de revient
pour tes pneus
un conseil ne dure pas nous avons mis la
main sur des déclarations écrites des
employés qui témoignent pourtant d'un
sérieux malaise
je vis un stress car je suis surveillé
sans savoir pour si j'avais le choix
j'irai pas dans cette sur la présence de
la caméra me rends 13 ans exclusion qui
cherche un repreneur depuis
l'installation de la caméra je marche
sur des rythmes et yves de me faire
apostropher par la famille moi je pense
upload enfantillages se lavant siège
pendant la vie d'aujourd'hui on
financement de technologies ou ni fumée
partout
[Musique]
à plusieurs reprises des images de
maltraitances de personnes âgées ont
fait les manchettes
la plupart du temps les caméras sont
cachés par ce qu'on soupçonne de la
maltraitance mais de plus en plus de
familles comme les richards revendique
le droit d'en installer tout simplement
pour se rassurer en surveillant leurs
proches et ça ça ne fait pas les
affaires des syndicats du domaine de la
santé
à partir du moment qu'on me massou sur
la surveillante même comme un individu
ça veut dire qu'on fait pas confiance
non plus à ma qualité professionnelle à
ma formation requise comme forte ma
formation j'ai acquise pour donner ses
prestations de travail la donne et ses
prestations de soins et c'est ce qui
vient à ce moment là aussi comme
travailleurs travailleuses m'affecter
guy lorient et vice président de la
fédération de la santé et des services
sociaux
ni contre les caméras de surveillance
parce que selon lui elle viole le droit
des employés à leur vie privée
moyon rien que mis en garantie à partir
du moment que je rentre dans la chambre
d'une utilisation de ces images
l'ouverture à l'extérieur
quelques jours après l'installation de
la caméra des richards le syndicat des
employés a réclamé son retrait immédiat
de son côté le centre de santé et de
services sociaux de saint léonard et
saint michel responsable du chs ld a
essayé de s'entendre avec la famille en
proposant une séance de médiation ce
point séance de médiation qu'ils
auraient proposé c'est qu'on se
rencontre contre aux intérêts des grands
pots des terrains d'entente pour relever
le cam héros ou bien aux mêmes caméras
puis on va vous donner des heures fixes
pour les films et où le regard des
suppôts besoin de seulement parce que
qu'est ce qui va se passer dans les
autres à ce poids seule bulle le centre
de santé et de services sociaux s'est
finalement adressé aux tribunaux pour
forcer la famille a retiré la caméra
premier argument la caméra contrevient à
la charte des droits et libertés parce
qu'elles violent la vie privée des
employés est le jeu plante souviens bien
car là dessus l'expectative de droit à
la vie privée de travail en khâgne et
dans la chambre d'un patient est il à
peu près nous
maître jean pierre ménard et l'avocat de
la famille richard owni d'enjeu mais
lieu particulier dans la chambre du
patient et d'ainsi matière dans la loire
prévoit bien clairement que pour le
passage derrière son milieu de vie
justice eu le bras mais chez elle
deuxième argument du centre de santé et
de services sociaux
la caméra viole la charte parce qu'elle
porte atteinte à la dignité de la
résidente nouveau cautionner une
captation d'image des soins d'hygiène
étaient moches et aux touristes jamais
j'accepterai une telle chose comme ça
même si la résidente est d'accord
troisième argument la caméra viole
l'article 46 de la charte qui garantit
aux employés le droit à des conditions
de travail justes et raisonnables nous
comme employeur au niveau du droit du
travail
on peut pas installer on n'est même pas
le droit d'installer une caméra comme ça
pour dire je vous surveille un employé
ou qu il se passe quelque chose ça prend
des motifs plus que raisonnable pour un
justifier l'installation des caméras pas
si c'est la famille qui l'installent
selon maître jean-pierre ménard
légalement ça ne prend pas de motifs
raisonnables si on a le moindre doute
que les services sont en forme
correctement on est tout à fait légitime
et d'un plat c'est une visible ou non
visibles elles n'existent aussi aucune
obligation déformer les autorités qu on
ne classe une caméra marie-claude maths
à cacher sa caméra sans dire aux
propriétaires de la résidence elle ne
soupçonnait pas de mauvais traitements
pourtant elle en a découvert à trois
reprises
on voit cette autre résidente venir
demander de l'aide pour remonter son
pantalon
on se demande pourquoi elle ne s'adresse
pas aux préposés puisque pour la mère de
marie claude matt se déplaçait est très
difficile en regardant ces images on se
dit qu'on a peut-être une partie de la
réponse
[Musique]
l'on voit ma marque ikon souche a aidé
en cela par la préposée le vois que ma
mère le père est là pour venir comme
camoufler ou minimisés on l'a on la voit
aller voir ma mère pu l'apprendre par
les épaules 1 est ce qu un plot à
dénigrer la personne âgée ça se fait
peur mais au cours des deux semaines
d'enregistrement
ce sont ces images qui ont été les plus
difficiles à voir pour marie claude mc
[Musique]
selon l'horloge des vidéos qui nous ont
été fournis la mère de madame matt tombe
à 23h21 et reste seul sur le plancher de
sa chambre pendant une heure et demie
avant que le préposé lui viennent en
aide et appelle l'ambulance non
l'horloge a appelé mais fram à sorges se
terminer c'est terminé parfois les
images captées sont sans équivoque
parfois elles sont trompeuses et peuvent
faire beaucoup de mal
ces cinq secondes de vidéo prise dans un
chsct du québec en 2005 ont roulé en
boucle dans les médias elles ont valu à
cette préposée d'être congédié et accusé
au criminel pour voie de fait la
préposée a été acquitté parce que le
juge a vu l'ensemble de la vidéo qui
selon nos recherches n'a jamais été
diffusée après l'arrivée dans la chambre
on voit la jeune femme s'occupait du
résident avec calme et douceur
elle lui fait même une accolade 7000 à
elle était seule avec 35 patients
le résident était tombé devant sa
chambre se débattait se frappait la tête
sur le sol incapable de le relever elle
l'a tiré dans sa chambre pensant qu'il
se calmerait dans un lieu familier la
préposée nous a raconté au téléphone
qu'elle avait été traumatisée par la
diffusion de ces images
une personne qui a besoin que le monde
même l eau tout le monde maïs et j'ai
été obligé de recommencer ma vie à zéro
je n'aurais jamais été capable de
recommencer à travailler comme préposée
ça c'est sûr
déjà que la confiance on le poteau jour
genre commence à la voir tranquillement
avec les années de thérapie
[Musique]
et
les caméras sont capables du meilleur et
du pire
il n'y a pas de lois particulières qui
régissent leur utilisation dans les chs
ld la cause de la famille richard allait
permettre à un tribunal de se prononcer
pour la première fois sur le droit des
familles d'en installer mais le 25 juin
dernier la mère de nathalie silva
richard est décédé
[Musique]
la juge aurait pu publier son jugement
quand même mais le centre de santé et de
services sociaux s'y est opposée les
richards ne seront donc jamais si la
juge aurait tranché en leur faveur est
un choc
je suis vraiment pas content avec cette
situation et nous parce que cela
déboucherait laquelle shing laisse le
dévoiler le juge jugement pourquoi votre
c3s a refusé que le juge public car même
sans jugement qui était prêt
l'injonction ne visait que ce colloque
dans ce cas pas pour régler les caméras
aussi à celle des impôts plus pour
régler les caméras dans les 6 3 et du
québec
pour nous le dossier au niveau de
l'utilisation de la caméra d'aloqa de
cette résidente le icloud un jugement en
faveur de la famille richard aurait pu
avoir un effet d'entraînement et
compliquer la tâche des gestionnaires
d'établissements si ça sert notamment la
surveillance des employés et que l'or
par exemple la famille intervient à 10
aux préposés aux bénéficiaires vous avez
beaucoup chez mon père de la bonne façon
c'est pour les techniques que je veux
j'avais sorti du linge pour ma mère hier
vous avez promis le bon lège sujet 448
léger 448 caméra j'ai 448 famille qui
interviennent auprès du personnel
j'espère est à ma retraite parce qu'on
est ingérable pour ce qui est de la
résidence la voisine hier nous avons
présenté plusieurs des vidéos de la
caméra cachée à son propriétaire
il a refusé de nous accorder une
entrevue mais nous a fait parvenir une
lettre dans laquelle il déclare que des
mesures ont déjà été entreprises afin de
procéder à une enquête et des sanctions
pourront être imposées au personnel
fautif
marie-claude matt est fière de ce
qu'elle a fait pour protéger sa mère
si on n'avait jamais mis de caméras
auraient coûté commun voulez vous qu'on
arrive à voir ces choses là 5e euros
impossible impossible
depuis un peu plus d'un mois la mère de
marie claude map a quitté la voisine
hier pour emménager dans un chs l idée
avez-vous été tenté caché une caméra
dans le nouvel endroit où elle est
hébergée
non pas du tout la con sans confiance
qu'à concentrent les gens nous écoutent
puis on est respecté on ne peut vous
donner notre camion
[Musique]
oh